hey what's up guys my name is Jenna and
welcome to episode 20 of network chat
programming okay so today we're going to
talk about how the server can I guess
distribute while only disagree but send
all of the connected clients a packet
that one client sends if that makes
sense probably doesn't what I mean is
that because this is going to be like a
you know a chat application in which a
like a numerous number of clients
connect to a central server that server
should of course relay a message that it
receives from any one client to all the
other clients okay so scenario is we've
got through clients connected via server
obviously the server is that central
point the server is where the packets of
data where the messages from the clients
gets sent once a set once the server
receives a packet from from client one
the server wants to distribute it to all
the other clients so client two in this
case right
so would that's really that's quite
easier to do right because we've got
this array list of all all of all of our
connected clients so um it should be
really really really simple for us to
actually just go ahead and say okay well
if you know if it's a message obviously
we we don't want to send details like
connection Packers but of course we are
we actually differentiate can actually
package from message packets by using a
prefix here of C in enclosed in false
lashes here so our goal right now is to
basically say that else if it's any
other kind of message then in fact we
shouldn't do that right because
sometimes what can happen is
applications break and somehow a backer
might get corrupted so instead of
instead of sending a bunch of garbage to
decline we can say that okay well else
if you know else if our string dot
starts with let's just go with M
rightful slash am full slash so if it
starts with M will also make an else
thing just in case something happens but
if it does start with them we kind of
want to send it to everything out to
everyone else now obviously we have a
sender method no yet okay well we can
deal with that but what we want to do is
we want to basically
send to all maybe I don't know it's
maybe that's a bit bad sand you know
we'll just go sent it all and we'll pass
in the actual string itself now probably
not no point actually passing in the
string itself because we should probably
go ahead and actually get rid of that so
oops
so string I guess message equals a
string dot substring and again we'll go
ahead and go three and then stream
length all right so the same thing that
we did here right and what that does is
it just it chops off the first three
characters of that string so and this
should be message whoops
message okay so that's looking good
right now
what else do we need we also oh that's
probably about it right that's actually
message to send so Center all let's go
ahead and create that method really
quick I'll just create it up here so you
guys to see both of those methods so
private void send to all and then string
message all right so the message we want
to send here is well the message that we
get right so that's the easy part
so what we should do is I don't think
we've got a we do over send a send
thread but what we'll do right now just
to simplify this as well as I'll just go
ahead and go say for in I equals 0 I is
less than clients I think yep that's
sighs I plus plus so for each of the
clients let's just go ahead and get the
client so client client equals clients
get I all right so that returns the
current client in our clients ArrayList
so let's import the the the Cherno one
of course so ah it's called server
client my bad serve a client all right
and we can probably get rid of that
import here the charger client right now
get rid of that just to keep everything
nice and tidy so
we've got the we've got the server
client now so we of course know these
server clients details if we go back
into serve a client of Java you can see
that we actually know the name well we
don't really know the name but we know
the address and we know the port so
that's good I guess
oh there's one more thing I should
probably mention okay one more thing
when the client sends something this is
actually perfect the way that the client
sends something is you can see here it
sends message like get bytes you know
let's just make sure that we do prefix
it with an M first of all so it does get
identified as a message we can just do
that simply like this I'm actually the
whoops that's not gonna work
because I think sand is going to send
wait what like calling into that one
chuckling this what hang on Matt what's
going on here how are we sending this
what's that calling okay good it's
calling that so um and that's sending a
but okay cool so when we actually grab
the message we'll just make sure that we
actually log the message we don't want
to do it here but let's just make
message equal over here after we print
it in the console message equal to M m4
/ m4 / plus the actual message as it was
before all right and then that'll
actually send it with the correct thing
there so let's go back to server vanilla
we get that and and the awesome thing is
right so it sets the name and that's
exactly what we want to print anyway so
we'll go ahead and we'll say client well
oh we haven't made a cent that's the
other problem I got to deal with that
but we essentially want to send it to
all the clients
okay and that's actually really easy to
do here so what we have to do right now
though is actually make a send method so
this episode's gonna be all over the
place
bribe avoids send okay and again that
will be kind of ident almost identical
to the server so byte data
so our almost identical to a client you
can see here in the client if we
actually look at this send method that
we got here it takes in a byte array of
data okay now that's cool okay and it
knows where to send it right it sends it
to IP and port and reason it knows what
I send it is because we connect to the
server so when we connect it server we
specify those details now as a server
clients connect to us in other words if
we want to send a packet of data we
actually have to specify for each backup
data where we want to send it so make
sure that you also have an address here
and a port number here okay in our send
method and don't forget to mark byte as
final all right so we'll import this and
then then it's just a matter of send
equals I think if we go over here then
you'll see it as well yeah it's just
making a new thread here and we're
sending the packet of data here and I
think that it does yep it does not
address brilliant so we'll go ahead and
make send equal new thread and we call
this the sent thread we'll have it as an
enormous a well in a body thing and of
course don't forget to actually start it
so public void run will make a new data
packet data ground packet first of all
because that will actually enclose our
data of course we'll call this our
packet equals new data ground packet our
data is our byte address is our
destination port is our thing and we
also of course have to specify the
length of data so data dot length so the
good thing here is we actually know the
length already so we don't need to go
ahead and make a new bit of data there
so address and port what's wrong with
that oh yeah so yeah they do have to be
final that the reason all these things
need to be filed because we really
pushing them over into an inner class
here um we shouldn't call it in a class
it's more of like an inner method
although it is in it and anyway I'm not
gonna deal with that now okay so and
then of course when you do actually send
it and the way we do that is we
a socket dot sand and a packet and again
the the packet dictates where needs to
go because that's another thing that a
lot of people common misconception is
that people think and and logically like
it kind of makes sense in a way people
think that the socket should tell the
packet where to go but that if that
doesn't really make sense if you think
about it a lot because if you picture a
real word a real-world example here it's
like saying that okay well when I when I
write a letter and I put into it like an
envelope and I send it over to put to
the post office the post office then
specifies where it needs to go like that
doesn't make sense right when you make
the end where we actually write the
letter you specify where it goes right
so the letter in this analogy of course
is the packet so the packet you write on
the packet this is addressed to this
address and then the post-office the
socket is like okay cool I'll send it
there okay so hopefully that makes sense
that was a some pretty good on the
flying creation of metaphors right there
anyway so that should run perfectly
right if we go to the client we can
verify that that's pretty much all we
had here and it looks exactly the same
which is great except for these added
fields so what we have to do now is
basically go ahead and say send so this
is going to do it for each of the
clients here sent and because by the way
because this is a new thread will allow
us to do this stuff concurrently so send
send and then our byte of data here
which will just be message dot get bytes
the address which of course is client
dot it gets you didn't do that stuff so
client is our client let's go back to
server client this stuff is public so
that makes it a lot easier for us so
client dot address I think it might be
um let's go back to server client real
quick I know it is a tricycle so client
on address and client port okay so yeah
that's pretty much it
what that will do is send the year the
provided message to all of decline
okay great now one thing we should also
do is this message it's uh I didn't
realize this earlier probably should've
this message actually should probably
still contain the prefix M okay so we
can forget this substring stuff and we
can simply just send these string as
itself all right and the reason we want
to do that is because if we send it that
way we don't need to prefix it here
again and do all those operations or we
just send it with with the default such
M at the front right like that and the
reason is because the client will also
receive different types of packets so it
might be like her are you still there
packet like a you know one of those
packets or or something like you know
you're getting kicked Oh or something
like that and then of course the client
will have to respond to that as it does
so anyway that's going to pretty much
wrap up this episode of network chat
programming next time we will take a
look at the client actually receiving
data because we haven't done that yet
and then will pretty much be done like
what we'll we'll do I think you guys
wanted me to do other stuff like um like
like like lists the container cool older
clients and we'll also have to do after
we did the the connection of sorry the
receiving of packets by the client will
also probably do console commands for
the server so that we can seal
everything that's every client is
connected and and stuff like that and so
that we can actually debug it a bit
better if something is not working or
kick clients and stuff like that but um
thanks for watching guys don't forget
that the source code is in the link
below there's a github link it's just in
case I forgot to put it in there or
something it's good Hub home for /the
Cherno for slash show no chat and there
you'll find every single episode and
it's a well source code so yeah anyway
if you did like the video please hit
like button it's a I like it when you
guys do that so please do that and I'll
see you guys next time goodbye